dossier des opioïdes la société
pharmaceutique purdue offrirait 11
milliards 500 millions de dollars
américains pour régler les poursuites
liées à la crise aux etats-unis pour
diot est accusé comme d'autres
entreprises d'ailleurs d'avoir créé une
épidémie en sous-estimant les dangers de
son analgésiques oxycontin pour mousser
ses ventes
plus de 400 mille personnes sont mortes
depuis 20 ans aux états unis en raison
de leur dépendance aux opioïdes
les dépenses en santé associés à cette
crise sont estimées à plus de 500
milliards de dollars selon des médias
américains pour diot a offert de se
placer sous la protection des tribunaux
et de créer un fonds qui permettrait de
lutter contre cette épidémie l'argent du
fonds viendraient notamment de la vente
qui se poursuit toujours du médicament
oxycontin et trois milliards seraient
fournis aussi par la famille derrière
purdue la famille saclay amylie quesnel
valley et titulaire de la chaire de
recherche du canada sur les politiques
et les inégalités de santé obtiennent
elle va des bons soirs mansart est-ce
qu'il est clair selon vous que les
pharmaceutiques ont faussé de marketing
des opioïdes pour en vendre plus depuis
des années même depuis des décennies
c'est ce qu'on comprend des dernières
décisions qui sont tombées notamment
celle du tribunal de l'oklahoma qui a
tenu johnson and johnson coupables et
leur a chargé 572 millions de dollars a
justement pour ces questions de
marketing et de promotion tromper on
parle de promotion trompeuse de
marketing agressif on sous estime les
conséquences des faces essentiellement
ils sont allés directement à la vente
aux médecins et leur ont vendus poste
shenzhen johnson mais les grandes
pharmaceutiques ont souligné que ces
nouveaux appuyé à longue durée avait peu
de chance de poser des dépendances ce
qui était faux
et en fait on sait que c'était faux
parce que les poursuites qui sont qui se
sont soulevés à ce moment là depuis les
20 dernières années en fait on fait
ressortir des documents notamment de
produits pharma et c'est pour ça qu'ils
se trouvent en au centre de la tempête
parce que leur médicament oxycontin est
également un des médicaments qui est
ciblé comme étant là
l'un des plus populaires et que les
pratiques depuis du produit phare très
agressif dans le marketing donc un peu
différemment à travers ces années aurait
eu des documents où ils ont développé en
fait des plans d'affaires où ils
soulignaient qu'ils allaient devenir des
leaders dans le champ de la
pharmaceutique pour ce qu'ils appelaient
tout le spectre de la gestion de douleur
jusqu'à la dépendance est donc dans ces
documents il reconnaissait en fait
explicitement que dans la gestion de
douleur il y avait un risque de
dépendance la gestion douleur donc en
donnant des médicaments de deux
ordonnances
il y avait un risque de dépendance et à
ce moment-là il offrirait des
médicaments qui irait jusqu'à la
naloxone qui permet de renverser les
effets d'une surdose donc il est très
clair et il ya des preuves écrites il ya
des documents dont vous parlez qui
montre clairement que ces médicaments
c'est opioïdes créé de fortes
dépendances
et il semble très clair aussi vous avez
préparé un graphique pour nous de
montrer que la prise dock ionides et les
dépendances aux véritables mof exploser
des surdoses mortelles
en fait oui pour prendre compte de
l'ampleur de la crise des qui se passe
aux etats unis
il faut on peut regarder ici ses
produits par les centers for disease
control de 1999 jusqu'à 2017 on voit
l'augmentation de la mortalité par cent
mille habitants ici d'abord la première
phase en orange on a les opioïdes
prescrits et ça inclut auxi côtés
notamment qu'ils comprendront qui est
produit par purdue pharma hockey qu'ils
rouvrent entre ici on voit la croissance
on est passé de deux à cinq ou six
mortalité par cent mille cent mille
habitants à
ce à travers leurs cours et ce qui est
également problématique c'est qu'à
travers le cours de cette période là on
voit aussi qu'il ya une augmentation de
l'utilisation de l'héroïne en bleu est
ici une augmentation exponentielle des
mentalités qui sont associées aux
opioïdes synthétique donc le fentanyl
par exemple qui fait des ravages
également au canada donc le fait analyse
jo plaide synthétique comme le fentanyl
c'est totalement illégal
c'est à dire s'il est légal c'est quand
c'est utiliser android de rue ce qu'on
voit ici dans les surdoses mortelles on
peut l'attribuer à des drogues illicites
et non à des utilisations médicales
parce qu'on peut retrouver le fentanyl
en utilisation médicale retrouvé très
contrôlés en utilisation médicale mais
vraiment et donc de façon illicite c'est
vraiment la ligne jaune
on voit très clairement une augmentation
due sur 12 mois est ce qu'on voit en
fait c'est qu'en 2017
on avait soixante dix mille américains
qui sont décédés des surdoses mortelles
et qui sont attribués aux opioïdes
donc ça c'est un nombre faramineux et
c'est ce qui a mené les centers for
disease control a déclaré un état
d'urgence
état d'urgence à un moment où
l'oxycontin et ses médicaments c'est un
analgésique rapporte beaucoup aux
entreprises même code l'oxycontin ça
rapporte et combine 25 milliards a perdu
pharma au fil des années ont fait d'eux
les années en profite en profite c'est
incroyable quand les faramineux mais
c'est faramineux et donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait à partir de ce constat de dire ben
voilà il ya eu abus donc il ya des
poursuites qui sont qui sont menées mais
il ya des ententes également que son
conclu johnson johnson a été condamné à
verser une amende mais dans le code
produit
il y aura une entente est-ce que c'est
assez 12 milliards si on regarde par
exemple le cas des grandes compagnies de
tabac aux états unis qui sont allés
également au recours ont conclu une
entente avec les états américains mais
se sont retrouvés à travers vers la fin
des années 1990 conclure une entente qui
les amène à payer 9 milliards par année
depuis aux états aux états unis l'argent
qui va aux états américains pour gérer
les conséquences de la consommation de
cigarettes
bien sûr il y avait beaucoup plus de
personnes qui consommaient des cigarette
qu'il fumait des cigares être que deux
personnes qui consomment des opioïdes
mais je pense que on voit l'ordre de
grandeur maintenant donc perdu farmer
effet 35 milliards de dollars de profits
ils ont été poursuivis ils ont eu
plusieurs ententes en cours qui les ont
amenés à payer plusieurs centaines
millions jusqu'ici
et là il s'en irait vers un autre une
entente de l'ordre de des dizaines de
12,6 à 12 milliards ça irait pas
nécessairement aux victimes cet argent
va aux différents gouvernements locaux
et étatiques et c'est ça quand on
reprend la question des ententes qui ont
été conclus avec les grandes compagnies
de tabac ce qui est dommage en fait
c'est de voir que dans plusieurs cas les
victimes de ces de cette épidémie la ont
pas été ceux qui ont reçu nécessairement
les services il en parlerait par exemple
à ce qu'on vous a montré les chiffres
qu'on vous a montré ce qu'on fait face
également au canada l'épidémie des
surdoses de drogue de rue notamment liée
aux fêtes annuelles il faut commencer à
s'adresser à la question de la
dépendance et des programmes de
prévention et de soutien aux personnes
et aux familles qui sont affligés
ils entendent perdu aujourd'hui touchent
les états unis mais paul quart d'heure
exactement donc en ce moment il ya deux
poursuites de la colombie-britannique et
de l'ontario qui sont menées contre les
grandes pharmaceutiques au niveau des
opioïdes de l'ordre d'1 1 milliard de
dollars canadiens
et il reste à savoir qu'est ce que
l'entente ici elle devait être conclu de
purdue pharma voudrait dire pour ces
poursuites là en permanence c'est quand
même un fléau les opioïdes il ya des
façons de se faire aider quand même si
on a un problème avec les opioïdes je
pense que c'est important de souligner
les ressources qui sont disponibles pour
les gens et puis je pense qu'on pourrait
aider les membres du cran en exergue
merci beaucoup et me dit qu'il veut
merci à vous